Dr. Aly Goodman, I'm a pediatrician and epidemiologist at CDC
in the division of Nutrition and Physical Activity and Obesity.
I'm a Senior Researcher for healthcare services.
And I'm Paula Braun.
I'm an entrepreneur in residence with CDC and the National Center for Health Statistics.
The public health challenge that we're addressing is pediatric obesity.
One in three US children are living with overweight or obesity,
both of which have major health consequences,
both for children and adults.
These consequences can be costly,
they can cause significant disability as children age.
And though, we've made some progress in public health in
terms of leveling off the prevalence or how many children have obesity,
we have a long way to go.
We still have approximately 12 million children in the US living with obesity,
four million of whom have severe obesity.
And with that, will come a lifetime of difficulties associated with that.
So, the challenge particularly in our area and in what I work in,
which is really at the intersection of healthcare and public health is,
how do we help clinicians and health service providers to
improve the uptake of evidence-based practices for child obesity?
And so, that includes screening,
which is a relatively simple process of weighing
and measuring a child's height at
every well-child check that most children get at least annually,
and then calculating their body mass index,
and plotting that on a CDC or World Health Organization growth chart,
to determine the child's percentile.
And by doing that, we can determine whether a child has a healthy weight,
is overweight, or has obesity.
And so, in public health,
we always say the first step is screening.
We have to determine how many kids have a problem.
And then clinically speaking,
if you don't determine,
you don't figure out that there is a problem,
then you can't possibly find a solution or help the child forward.
The second issue, of course,
is then preventing or treating a child's issues related to healthy weight.
And our best evidence suggests that,
when clinicians do some brief counseling on nutrition and physical activity,
determine whether a family is actually ready to make some changes,
and if they are,
offering or referring them to
a intensive pediatric weight management program, that's really multi-disciplinary,
it's family-oriented and typically occurs in the community and delivers
at least 25 hours of services over a six-month period.
So, all of those different clinical factors
can be assisted by an electronic health record
that supports the clinician in
making the right decisions such that you can best help the family.
In addition, the electronic health record can support program evaluation.
So let's say that a clinic health care system,
even a community system,
decides to do a variety of different activities to try to
help children or families living with overweight or obesity,
the data that are contained on a child's height, weight,
and body mass index in an electronic health record already are extraordinarily valuable.
So that you can look before the intervention and after the intervention and determine if
there's been any changes in the child or family's weight status.,
You can look at different behaviors,
all sorts of things.
And then lastly, electronic health records are poised to
really assist us in public health with something called surveillance,
which is the determining of how many people in a population have a particular disease.
And so, in the case of pediatric obesity,
we have national level data,
but we don't have a very good state or community level data in order to
provide feedback to public health programs, interventionalists, et cetera.
And that's where again,
because all these children are being seen,
their body mass index is being calculated,
is being plotted on this growth charts,
all those data are sitting in electronic health records.
And they could really assist us in public health and to really
move the needle in terms of improving child obesity.
Yes, it really just
started with a conversation between Dr. Goodman and myself.
Part of my role at CDC is to work with different people in
the agency and get them to experiment with and hopefully adopt these newer technologies.
And it was very apparent that the work that we were doing in
mortality could be applied across other sectors,
particularly around public health surveillance.
As I was showing Aly the SMART on FHIR app that had already been
developed to address aspects of pediatric obesity,
and we thought that,
that was just such a great place to start.
And because the code was publicly available,
we were able to extend it and adapt to this use case.
And so, it was more than just what happens in a clinical setting.
It was a recognition that childhood obesity is
really something that takes an entire community approach to address.
And, we imagine a world where
all of the interoperability challenges had already been solved.
What information would we want to provide to whom?
And what would they do with that information?
And over the course of the semester,
the project really took on a life of its own and it continued to evolve.
I think we called it the dream, right?
So, what's the dream which was connecting patients and providers?
And then having excellent care coordination that
then connected providers to communities, community resources,
public health and then having bi-directional flow between all of those entities
in order to sort of maximize what you're doing as a community,
in order to get better effect,
which has been shown in lots of studies to be the best way to address
child obesity in a community and for specific children as well.
The apps evolved over time. It was pretty interesting.
The first semester, we divided it up into four apps.
One that faced towards a patient,
another towards the provider,
a third towards a care coordinator,
who was really interfacing with community resources.
And then lastly, an analytics app that could
do some of the work that we discussed before,
regarding looking at different numbers and so looking at
prevalence of obesity by all kinds of different cut points,
something we do a lot in epidemiology and public health.
So that's how it started.
And then, I had met some providers at
Children's Healthcare of Atlanta and they're Strong for Life program,
which works on pediatric obesity in the Atlanta area.
And they had a project that they were doing with Georgia WIC,
the women's and children's program which
provides supplemental nutrition assistance to women and children under age five.
And, what they were doing was trying to connect pediatric primary care providers and
the WIC nutritionists and facilitate
communication through the electronic health records of both of those providers,
to see if improve communication could lead to
improvements in a child or family's nutritional status.
And so, we worked with them and started modifying
several of the apps that we had created for that use case,
which is a little bit different than the first one.
And then from there, we went on
to the next team of students really wanted to work on privacy and security,
and particularly on that patient facing app,
that base towards families,
where they could interface then or carefully work closely with their provider team.
And then, the last most recent iteration was,
how can we integrate breastfeeding information.
Breastfeeding is really important for women and children.
We know that it is an important intervention for children's and women's health.
And, we also know that it can be
associated with healthier weight over a child's lifetime,
actually and for the mother, too, over time.
And so, integrating that information into the apps created just another,
it wasn't really a change in the use case, I guess,
was more like an addition as to how can we integrate other information.
Sure. Here, we see the original patient-facing app.
It gathers information from the family directly and
the child's healthy habits information.
So specifically, in this screen,
what you see is a picture of fruits and vegetables.
We're asking the family about how many times per day the child eats fruits or vegetables.
And you can see on the bottom that the family can pick from one of five options.
So, those options and that question itself have been tested in
numerous clinical trials and different studies and shown to be
a relatively effective measure of looking at that very important information.
So, it helps the family not only reflect
on how they're doing in terms of fruits and vegetables,
but also that information is really critical to the provider,
because when they start discussing nutrition,
they know where the family starting from.
The next app is the provider-facing app
which is the one that was largely based on information or coding,
and the app that was built by Boston Children's as their growth-chart app.
But we were able to add some additional features that are helpful for
clinicians as they're tracking growth including extra data points.
Third, we have the care-coordinator app.
We were really impressed with this one.
The concept was that when a provider clicked on a button and sort of said,
"Please refer this family to community resources," the app could take
the information from the electronic health record on the patient or families address,
and then map community resources that were nearby their home.
And so, in this app,
you can see they developed a map that could show
the family where a variety of resources to support
healthy eating and active living were relative to where the family lives.
So here, you see nutrition support resources including the Tower Grove Farmer's Market,
and different markets, and community supported agriculture spot.
In addition, this app allowed secure messaging
between community resources and the provider.
Because as a provider,
very often when we refer families to community resources,
it's sort of a black box.
We make the referral, but then we have no idea
whether they've gotten there, what happens there.
And we try to ask families and find out how things are going.
Very often, the visits that we have with families as clinicians are very short.
It's very difficult to get all the information.
So, it's quite helpful to have that information ahead of time,
be able to look at it before you walk in to see the family.
And so, here you can see this combined inbox that
allows a care coordinator to see, "Oh, look.
This family went to the Farmer's Market.
They completed a questionnaire for the doctor.
They actually did get to the YMCA and scheduled an appointment."
And so, picking up as a clinician from that information and moving forward with
the family is just a much more efficient way
of providing prevention and treatment options.
Lastly, you see here a screenshot of the analytics app.
And the concept here is that it's taking information on some sort of population,
whether that's the population of patients that the physicians sees,
or within a practice group,
or even larger health-care system.
And it's combining that information on lots of kids,
and then slicing and dicing it in all different ways.
And so here, we've got some charts on blood pressure amongst the population, weight,
and BMI, and you can display that in different formats.
FHIR was an essential part of this project,
especially in thinking about potential scalability issues.
FHIR presents a common way of fetching information from the electronic health record.
It also provides through,
the SMART on FHIR platform,
the ability to add functionality to electronic medical records that didn't exist before.
Aly spent a lot of time talking about
the Boston Children's app that we modified for this project.
But the other apps also could be SMART on FHIR projects.
So, the patient-facing app,
the care-coordinator pacing app.
And FHIR provided the lingua franca,
that just allowed everything to be able to communicate with one another and ensure that
the information went where it needed to go and that people
had it at their fingertips when they were making critical decisions.
Well, this is an exciting project that has evolved.
And as I understand, it will continue to evolve
in future variations in the class.
So, thank you both for taking the time to come here today and talk about it.
Thank you.
Anything else?
I think we got plenty.
Do we want future iterations?
You had said you wanted that but do you not?
We can do it.
Do you have a sense of where it's going at?
Since we're sitting here.
Yeah, we might as well do it.
So, that would be?
That would be Aly.
Yeah.
So Aliy, this project has gone through several iterations.
I understand you have still more for the future.
Can you tell us a bit about that?
Sure. We're really excited to keep developing these technologies.
We actually got to showcase some of these recently at the Hymns 2017 Conference.
And we were flabbergasted quite frankly by their response,
and how excited clinician's,
public health professionals, and health-care executives were,
to actually see clinical apps that were dealing with a very prevalent problem,
solving so many issues regarding communication,
clinical decision support, analytics,
population health, all of that.
And so based on that excitement,
we are next going to hopefully partner with some academic researchers who
really are absolute experts in the field of
clinical decision supports for pediatric obesity.
And these are clinical decisions supports that have been
tested in multiple research studies.
It have shown to be effective.
So, we're going to go back to our apps,
go back to our code,
and sort of re-adapt and reinvent those
clinical decision supports to be in line with what these researchers are working on,
with the hope that
the researchers will be able to actually
implement them in real clinics with real families,
and test whether those supports through the apps actually lead to a change in behaviors,
or weight status for children, or their families.
I'm glad we asked that question.
Yup.
Now I think we're done.
Okay. That's all that you get condensed to 10 minutes.